i think wokism has evolved into
something meaningless
and so
what the problem is there are a lot of
more
philosophically mature individuals who
can look at the literature look at uh
the frankfurt school look at critical
race theories origins kimberly crenshaw
derek bell et cetera on the things
they've said and try to make sense of it
the problem is while these things may
have been contributing factors to what
locism has become woke-ism is more akin
to a fire it is reckless it is wild it
spreads it consumes and destroys
and if you take a look at a lot of the
big cancel culture moments of the past
decade they actually don't align towards
any ideology so my favorite example of
the contradictions of the woke are when
there was a woman's organization that
tweeted the word wimixon oh yes i wrote
so by the way so did elizabeth warren
that's the moment i thought oh my like
elizabeth
sets herself up as this great
intellectual uh you know policy person
and then what is she doing just total
pandering madness so this organization
tweets the word w-o-m-x-n
it's like adherence of wokism though
said that's offensive how dare you
create a different word that implies
trans women are not women and so now you
simultaneously have the word woman being
non-inclusive and being inclusive and we
mix in being both simultaneously not
exclusive and inclusive there is no
appropriate thing you can say that can
be determined to be acceptable to woke
other than to drop to your knees and
adhere to the power structures there's
no moral framework there's no logic
guiding their principles it is just we
win period it is more like a swarm of
wasps than any functioning ideology yeah
and again i'll stress when we look at
the frankfurt school and we look at you
know weimar germany and antifa and the
anti-fascist you know protection rampart
the berlin wall and all of the history
that leads today
people
mathematically oriented people are
trying to calculate and analyze
and they're missing the
what's really going on a chaotic
destructive force that will say and do
anything to
win i think that's very i agree with um
with that and i think that the other bit
i'd add to it is the way that so many is
the co-op the way that so many
institutions have been co-opted into it
in a totally superficial way in
particular if you think about corporate
america i think that's a really great
example where the the way that this is
spread like wildfire your analogy is a
good one through corporate america and
they suddenly kind of announced they're
going to have their training sessions
and robin d'angelos the set text and all
this kind of stuff they haven't thought
about it those you know the the hr
departments and the city they haven't
sort of bothered to re it's just like oh
this you know we better do this because
everyone's going on about it and our
employees are gonna you know and we've
got this vocal minority of our employees
who are saying why aren't we doing our
training or whatever it may be or social
media a few vocal people and so they're
all going for it without even giving it
a moment's thought it's totally
superficial and it's that's why the
virtue signaling i think is just such a
big part of it it's meaningless it's
it's just
are you in line with the cult or not and
if you're a part of it exactly right
then
exactly swarm will attack i think a lot
of this chaos is deliberate i i the
first thing that comes to mind is the
famous saying order out of chaos and
when you look at a lot of very prominent
elites whether it's ted turner henry
kissinger rockefeller they're the ones
that were very instrumental in opening
up china to the world and cheering on
what
what was happening during the cultural
revolution and their population control
efforts and you see a lot of these very
powerful individuals also now call for
the great reset to build back better and
implement similar policies that
essentially are creating the western
world into being this kind of orwellian
chinese
social credit score system that i think
that they've been trying to do here and
i think one way that they will be
successful in doing that is by dividing
and conquering having people fight each
other on trivial differences on absolute
nonsense as they get away uh with
pulling off this this great reset as
everyone is is chaotic
can you just talk about i've heard that
phrase and i i don't really know what it
what you what what's your favorite
phrase
i know is that a what is that well
that's that's a phrase used by many
powerful individuals especially within
the world economic forum by individuals
like klaus schwab uh there's a a lot of
corporate heads there's a lot of
billionaires there's uh you know even
the pope came out said that he's making
a corporate coalition of people in
industry that will put on the great
reset uh the world economic forum
described it as people owning nothing
having no privacy and being happier than
ever and this is of course it's their
phrase
yes
and then you see many prominent
politicians say we need to implement to
the great reset we're here to build back
better biden's policy his quote
infrastructure bill is literally called
the build back better plan where he
talks about you know printing trillions
of dollars and spending it on equity
efforts and other social climate issues
that of course are the absolute opposite
of what they pretend to be so so
claustrophobic
i want to go on uh i'll give you this i
just get very excited every time i see
the world at davos i get i anyway here's
a simple version we have right here this
website worldeconomicforum.org
slash great dash reset yeah this is
something on their website it's not
right it's the media that's why media
has tried covering it up claiming it was
a conspiracy theory the gist of it is
they saw i'll tell you they put out a
video it said you will own nothing and
you will be happy by 2030. they wrote an
article where they said like your living
room will be used for business meetings
when you're not around you won't own
things you'll just use things that are
available to you you'll have no home or
bedroom people will come and use your
stuff as however they see fit what
they're ultimately trying to say is
they think say that globals what is it
stakeholders global stakeholder uh
there's an urgent need for global
stakeholders to cooperate and
simultaneously managing the direct
consequences of the covet 19 crisis to
improve the state of the world the world
economic forum is starting the great
reset initiative
you will own nothing where are you
getting that from that's this is the
world economically no no you will owe
nothing what's that about so that's
that's a video they produced and
ultimately deleted that said the the
famous line from it put it on twitter no
nothing you will own is that you will be
happy from one of their people it was it
was their corporate view it's it's their
official view it was it was an official
world economic forum statement that was
put out so that you take a look at what
joe biden has been doing he wants to
shut down another oil pipeline he shuts
down keystone he bans fracking
the with with the crisis at the ports
with the crisis of inflation with the
constant lies from the media first they
said there's no inflation then they said
there's some inflation it's not a big
deal transit it's transitory then they
said it's going to end now they're
saying it's here to stay now they're
saying inflation's actually a good thing
so what's happening is all across the
board there's a labor shortage there's a
product shortage there's an energy
crisis in the u.s and i got to tell you
no
it may it may be conspiratorial
but when they come out and say build
back better is the slogan of of their
project in the great reset and then joe
biden says we're gonna build back better
and this is the buildback better bill
isn't it more absurd wouldn't occam's
razor suggest that to deny they're
actively trying to destroy the economy
would be the conspiracy no i don't think
that i think that you know i want to
look i want to be fair to what i think
they mean um which is
and actually i suspect underlies this
even though they've i mean i can't stand
devil he tried to sue me because i i
wrote some piece about him being totally
corrupt which he is he is um and um and
i've had first-hand experience of it in
terms of how
they approach participants in the
conference you know and how he's
siphoned off the money um and i wrote
put it in a newspaper article which i
think the headline wasn't like attending
davos should be as shameful as
as running a sweatshop or something
whatever anyway he went nuts in the
whole thing um but then um the
with with the bill back so i'm very
happy to like have a go at davos any
moment of any day with the buildback
that i think what they what certainly
what they're getting i think and i would
say not all of this is crazy is to say
that what you've seen as a result of the
pandemic um is all sorts of things that
are broken about how we organize the
economy and and society that actually we
could do with fixing one really obvious
example of that i think is our
dependence on china the fact that so
many of the you know pharmaceuticals are
made in china and so on you know i think
that that's a great example of something
that the the pandemic has revealed to
everyone i mean i've been making that
argument for a long time in my first
book
decoupling from china you know except
now what what joe biden's policies i'm
not saying he's doing the right thing
it's actually bolstering and emboldening
china but let's just try and be fair so
i think what they
that's an example it sounds like we
would agree about okay they would say um
well another example is the kind of
precariousness of people's working lives
and therefore um we need to do things
that will help that with and that that's
a lot of the driving force behind some
of the stuff in the spending board but
you know and even there i'd agree with
some of that but they're just saying
it's not the job of the federal
government to do it yeah you should be
doing it at the state level or the local
level whatever but i i don't think that
they
i don't know what do you think they're
the ones that created their dependency
on china they're the ones that are
creating the modern problems in this
world so for the people who come and
create the problem by the way literally
literally they're the people like the
guy steve rochetti who's who is the
senior whatever he's called count like
senior advisor i think is his title in
um the white in in biden's team he's the
number one guy right yeah he's been
involved in putting all these bills
together he was there he was the guy who
orchestrated try under the clinton um
administration china's entry into the
world trade organization yeah and he's
like totally corrupt i mean his
brother's running a lobbying firm have
you talked about all this i don't know
on the show i don't know literally his
brother is running a robbing firm who's
whose kind of clients have spectacularly
increased just in the last few months
surprise surprise because he's got his
brother's right there in the white house
with biden so you have the people
causing the problem offering up the only
solution yeah so when people are
suffering because they can't find work
they can't find enough they can't make
enough money because because of
inflation they're they're uh struggling
with shortages across the board these
are all problems created by the federal
government and then they want to make
you more dependent on that and now
they're coming out saying here's the
solution to all those problems i agree
with that problem reaction solution is
something that people talk about a lot
it's the same people who created it the
same people who are coming in with a
solution and the solution benefits them
even that much greatly i mean if you
look at what they're doing right in the
name of helping people they're limiting
people's ability to travel they're
limiting people's ability to earn money
they're limiting people's ability to
have a family to have a happy productive
life and what they're doing is we
literally have witnessed one of the
largest transfers of wealth in recorded
human history during the lockdowns which
helped out the billionaire class and
screwed everyone else over and then we
are seeing people's wealth literally be
eviscerated robbed right in front of
them as billionaires have made off with
the most amount of money almost in all
of recorded human history we're talking
about trillions of dollars being
transferred from poor middle class
people going to of course the schwabs
the bezos the gates's and all these
other individuals that are living by a
different set of rules that get to do
whatever they want as they tell you that
you are living beyond your means that
they're flying around in their private
jets on their beachfront properties
saying i know what's right for you i
need more power i need more money i will
tell you exactly how to live your life
and i refuse to be a slave or peasant
under that kind of system because that's
exactly the system that they want they
want you eating bugs they want you in a
pod they want you as a little unhealthy
fat depressed
and i refuse to live life best part
is when these same people who there's
there's two big ones obviously when they
fly in private jets to climate summits
but when they say the water levels are
rising and then buy beachfront property
i'm i'm not i i think climate change is
a big problem i think humans are
absolutely contributing to a lot of
ecological collapse but how am i
supposed to support you know you know i
think i genuinely believe
they use the urgency
of ecological disaster things we can see
and measure like the windshield
phenomenon bug populations colony
collapse disorder to scare people into
giving them up giving up their power so
they can buy beachfront property so they
can get private jets so you know but
they're the ones causing the ecological
disasters they're the ones the military
industrial complex is one of the biggest
polluters in the world we we haven't
even had that discussion yet the the
corporations in china they're the
they're the elites on the titanic and
they're stealing the fine china and then
jumping in a life but well before anyone
knows what's happening thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast if you want to watch
live you can check out this channel
monday through friday at 8 00 pm and
don't forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests
go to timcast.com and become a member
all of these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time